so when Chris comes in to visit Ben the
running gag of Ben loving calzones which
we've established already in the
previous season oh can I can I drip back
for one second just on Champion the
three oh yeah because when I was
watching it last night I remember so
vividly going to Mike uh because this
was that like I wasn't there that day I
said a three-legged dog I I said an
animation absolutely I said live action
that could be really sad oh yeah yeah
and I I was really worried about it and
and Mike had he just you know confidence
and he said no he goes I think it'll be
funny because of you know uh Andy's love
Andy and April's love for this dog I
think it'll work and I remember being so
worried and when I saw the dog I was
like oh my God is are people gonna find
this funny but then once the scene
starts and you same is exactly what Mike
said you know uh Chris you know Andy's
pride of this he's the you know
three-legged dog champion of the world
why he named him champion and there's so
much joy in his face at this uh I was
like yo I'm wrong again yeah yes it is
the same it's that same energy that
makes you love the fact that they got
married a few episodes after like saying
I love you or kissing it's the same Andy
and April getting married the same thing
about there's something endearing about
the meeting off frisbees as their plates
that they just make this weird life work
and seem ideal in a way yeah the
champion became a big part which I know
that's concerning because now we got a
three-legged dog involved yeah but
there's other episodes I mean in the
sweet 16 he gets lost and that's the
whole thing you got a three-legged dog
who no one knows where he is remember
when uh oh yeah yeah yeah and and Ben to
your point Scully Ben has that there's a
great line where he says like I have to
ask like did he have
four legs or whatever where did he
already have four legs when you got him
right yeah and it's so funny because it
just calls it it calls out the question
that we're all thinking at home like no
we're gonna establish it this is just
this great dog and we we really love him
yeah right yeah and I I like this quick
moment when Champion walks in and Ben
sitting there eating his cereal and name
it you know and I'm just so good hi yes
hi I got this three-legged Little
Creatures I just love that I also
noticed something last night that I
never know I always writing for uh Pratt
uh for Andy in my head was a lot like
writing for Homer uh in many ways but I
was last night his face the joy in his
delivery of like the champion thing I've
like who does he remind me of and this
is an old you might Tommy Smothers of
the Smothers Brothers has this great
facial expression this kind of wide-eyed
joy and and naive it all looks at all
yeah and that's what it was when I
watched Pratt do it last night yeah yeah
because as a kid I love Tommy's mothers
the audience can look him up yes
yeah I think we refer to him as like a
golden retriever yes dog in the in the
room like just that Joy of like what's
next yeah I love it yeah that was always
uh that was uh John schwarzwelder's
description of Homer when asked like how
do you write Homer Simpson he says think
think about writing for a dog that can
say his name
oh
foreign